- I feel like I'm about to take a test
that I studied for my whole life.
("Happy People")
- I don't think that men need sex toys.
- I'm pretty happy with masturbating.
- Well, I think women maybe have more
specific needs sexually than men do.
- For me I can bump into a
table and have an orgasm.
- Dicks aren't complicated.
Cobra Libre Two.
Am I gonna understand this one
if I haven't used the Cobra Libre One?
- I mean, it looks like
a Tron light-cycle.
- So you put the head
of your penis in here.
- Kind of like turning my penis into Bane.
I feel like it's just
gonna make me dehydrated.
("Happy People")
- Op, and they get right to it.
- Uh, OK.
Well this feels a little
objectifying. (laughs)
- This is like my fantasy of being
with Mystique from the X-Men,
except for she's not there
and I'm putting my penis in a cup.
- Oh, it's not really pleasant.
Oh, no, I guess I get it now.
- This looks like a prop
from a Cronenberg movie.
This is why there's a stigma
'cause when we're left to our own devices
this is the kind of shit we do with it.
I can't wait to use it though.
("Happy People")
- I really have to put my dick in this?
- It looks like Mac from "Mac and Me."
- OK.
- Oh OK, I get it now.
- I'm definitely looking
forward to this one.
- Well, it was an experience
like I wasn't expecting.
- I'm gonna be thinking about
this for the rest of my life.
- It was a really humiliating
experience for me,
and probably the Fleshlight.
- It was awesome!
It was awesome!
- The alien blue Fleshlight
was (laughs) unbelievable.
I don't feel like I would use it again,
but I'm certainly not throwing it out.
- I don't know if I'm a feminist anymore.
I don't know if I can call myself that.
And it's cold.
- Something about how detached
from sex it is is weird.
- Absolutely understand
why there's a stigma.
- This experience definitely took away
a lot of the stigma from it for me
because now I have had sex with a machine.
I can't go back.
- It was actually like a
somewhat pleasant jostling.
This I could kind of
recommend in a sense that
well, if you're bored watching
football or something.
- I could see using these with a partner
as just like a weird way to
change things up or whatever.
- I haven't gone to church
in probably 20 years,
and I feel the need to go to church.
- [Man with Beard] It felt wrong.
It felt really wrong.
- [Blond Man] So is my
face gonna get blurred out,
'cause if my mother gets an
iPad for Christmas this year
and sees this, her tears will be the lube
that the universe needs for the rapture
to fucking enter it.